hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round three of the
2013 candidates tournament I thought I'd
skip all the way to round four but there
is still one more get in one more game
we have to check out from round three as
the game is really exciting and it's
it's quite masterful now most of you
have heard the old saying by a Rudolph
Spielman I play the opening like a book
the middle game like I'm like a magician
and the end game like a machine this
game is something like that although
although the middle game is not played
as if a magician would play it but there
is there is a reason to that as I
mentioned in Game one and Game two from
round three all the players in every
round weren't serious time trouble so
such is the case in this game but you'll
see what I mean by this and it's very
interesting that Roger Buell goes for a
very exciting line of the Kings Indian
defense but what's what doesn't really
go his way is that Peter Svidler has
this position analyzed all the all the
way to move 17 so that's kind of
unfortunate for a job of but all in all
a very interesting game we have d4 by
sweedler and Knight to f6 c4 g6 so the
Kings Indian defense Knight to c3 and
Bishop to g7 so the standard variation
we have B 4 B 6 + f3 we have the semi
variation we have castles a Bishop to e3
c5 Knight G to e2 Knight to c6 and d5
now Knight to a5 and knights to g3
we have a 6 Bishop to e2 and now Knight
to d7 and Rajah was spent really a lot
of time on this move on this Knight to
d7 move preparing a pawn sacrifice would
be 5 rook to c1 but as I've mentioned a
reverse wheeler is prepared for this as
he has this position analyzed b5 now
comes the pawn sacrifice captures
captures and Bishop captures on b5 this
is a well I don't think if it's a
standard upon sacrifice for Kings Indian
defense but if you're if you're for
example a Benko player then you know
that you can give up the a and B pawn
set up your rooks on a file bring the
other rock over to be file and then the
rooks on on the a file and be file and
this dragon on g7 cutting the the board
in half will be compensation enough for
this pawn so a similar idea in this line
of the Kings Indian defense Knight to e5
we have castles and now Knight a to C
for attacking the bishop on e3 Bishop to
g5 we have Bishop to d7 but should
capture screen captures and now Queen to
E - this is move 17 and here a Reserve
will really struggle or struggled with
this line and here you probably want to
simply continue building up the pressure
you give up a pawn you want to create
some breathing space for your King force
this Bishop to decide where it wants to
go after after the bishop moves for
example Bishop to h4 there's there's
really no danger of a move like g5 if if
black decides the trap dovish would g5
you can simply push f4 you attack the
knight and then you know it's off it's
all it's all fine so after something
like well you could capture it or maybe
I don't know for example if you capture
then you you even can go into into a
very nice attack with Knight to f5 then
Queen to g4 is coming so after black
decide of course you can't move the
knight if you move the knight for
example 96 then you will get Queen
captures on c4 the other night is
undefended so the white will win back
the piece nevertheless but all in all
after this Queen to eat to move h6 would
be the best idea and after something
like Bishop to h4 simply bring the other
rook over to the B file and you know you
play on the position this is what you
give up a pawn for you have beautiful
rocks and EA and B file and you have a
bishop on g7 but after Queen to e2 again
our job of spent some time and he
decided to go Knight captures on b2 he
gives up two pieces for the rook so
swiller accepts this queen capture some
b2
we have Knight 2 D 3 now attacking the
Queen and the rook and c1
Queen to d2 and now
Knight captures rook captures and now
and even an even stranger move Bishop
captures on c3 giving up your strong
bishop for this night rook captures you
have to capture with the work if you
capture with the Queen then you allow
this point to be captured and this pawn
will prove to be very important in this
game so rook captures on c3 and now a
job of plays rook F to b8 Queen to c2
and Queen to c2 is is a master move well
he's a grandmaster so obviously it's a
grandmaster move I just wanted to say
that it's a it's a spectacular move
because Queen to c2 is preparing Bishop
to c1 and after Bishop returns to c1
dense feeder will push this point to a 3
and then the bishop will guard upon an
a3 and this Bishop and pawn I will
completely counter at a job of rooks and
the a and B file so we have f6 Bishop
does come to c1 and now Queen to a for
offering a trade of Queens so we will
replace a 3 and we have King to f7 you
might think okay but why not capture
capture and rugby 1 now this Bishop is
pinned and next move I'm gonna capture
white will simply play King f2 so you're
not really gonna capture anything here
but okay after a 3 acting to f7 we have
night 2 f1 and now Queen captures rook
captures and now f5 and there's really
no way sometimes a rock a rock can
compensate for a bishop the play against
a bishop in the night but here in this
position the two rooks are unable to
gain any activity because this bishop
and the pawn are really dominating the
rooks so night to d2 we have looked way
for Knight comes to see for now now the
night is also defending the a 3-point so
the bishop can move F captures pawn
captures and rook to b3 we have King to
f2 and now King to e8 e 5 we have worked
to a6 pawn captures pawn captures and
King to e2 King to d7 Bishop to f4 and
here here a job oh sweet or Villa will
start his attack two more
the d6 pawn so the way he's gonna do
this he has to bring this rook all the
way here and then with a triple attack
on this point he will be able to capture
it but it's it's a very interesting
variation and you will also be able to
you know join in in the calculations h5
we have h4 rook to a4 and then now King
to d2 rook to be one there's really no
way to activate the stroke anywhere
along the third-ranked all of these
squares are guarded the Bishop and pawn
here are guarding them very nicely
so Brooke to be one maybe maybe try to
activate the rook from behind King to c3
now the King is guarding tonight and
then out the rook and C 2 can be
activated
rook to a six and now rook to e 2
preparing rook rook here and then both
of these pawns will be under attack rook
to d1 attacking the d5 pawn ok white
cannot defend this pawn but but he's not
he doesn't intend to we have rook after
sangee 5 and our captors on g6
first grabbing this pawn rook back to d4
now the bishop on f4 is attacked and now
here is a very important question in
this game all of these pieces are
attacking the d6 pawn can you capture
the pawn and if so with what can you
capture it okay of course you will not
capture it with the night as the knight
has to protect the a3 pawn but if you
can capture it will you captured with
the night with the bishop or with the
rook so here is a nice position for you
to analyze you know you are Peter
Svidler
you're you're either gonna win this game
or you're gonna mess up and not win this
game because you do have advantage you
have a knight and the bishop against the
rook and the chances are you are winning
this game because you are so far ahead
on time so for those of you who were
able to figure it out congratulations
you are an excellent endgame player and
for those of you who for some reason
just won't enjoy the show here Bishop
captures and these six was played on the
other hand for if you play rook yup
force on d6 that's not so great
because here after rook captures Bishop
captures and rook and Bishop captures
the rook can capture an h4 and now it's
not all that clear black also grabs a
pawn and what do you do here of course
black will not grab two pieces for the
rook because then White has three points
two two that's a winning endgame for
white so rook captures on h4 and now
after Bishop captures on c5 rook to h2
and now black will simply pushes pawn
and whatever White does simply captures
captures you have to react and now black
black will be able to prevent prevent
this pawn all black has to do is give up
this rook for this night
for example if white immediately starts
pushing then you can simply capture the
night and after Bishop captures you have
the wrong Bishop this pawn has to
promote on a light square you have a
dark square bishop so there's no way for
you to win this
the King will simply go into the corner
and there's no way for you to get the
King out of the corner you will either
stalemate him or you'll agree to a draw
so this was a very important moment in
this position as wheeler played Bishop
captures on d6 which is the correct move
and now you have rook captures on h4 of
course now rook captures and d6 doesn't
work because if root sorry after Bishop
to d6 if rook captures on d6 then rook
captures rook captures and Knight
captures here white white forced black
to go into a losing game game now it's
three points against two and this is
completely winning for white simply king
c4 you will push the a pawn you will
force the King to go after the a pawn
you will capture the C pawn and then you
wind eh pawn and then you have to
connect it passed pawns on the Queen
King side are completely winning game so
after Bishop to d6 swittel grabs the
pawn rook captures on h4 buyer job of
Knight to e5 temporarily temporarily
giving up the defense of the a3 pawn but
this comes with check and the King can't
go anywhere here so the King has to go
back King see it now comes first of
course you cannot grab the pond just yet
because your rook would be
so wrote to GE check King to b7 and all
in Alba shop captures on c5 now the
bishop is guarding the a3 pawn so all is
well
rook to e6 attacking the knight we have
rugby ruby g7 check King see it and now
Knight the c-4 rope to g4 offering a
trade of rooks to get this pawn further
down down the board and then maybe rook
can grab this pawn and here you can
capture and this will in fact be still
winning for white but Svidler gets
another idea he goes Knight to d6 check
tink the b8 and now Rock The Rock the b7
check only move for the King his scheme
to a8 and now he plays rook to d7
threatening rock to the 8th checkmate
and as a reserve is in time trouble you
do have to quickly figure out to move
rook to G it was played defending
checkmate but now comes Knight to c4
rook captures and g2 there really isn't
a better move for black here other than
capturing the pawn so he did rook
captures and now comes a Bishop to d6
now as you see the King has nowhere to
go
Bishop is guarding b8 so there's again
the threat of knights to b6 checkmate
and there's really no way to stop this
other than to give up the rook for the
bishop so Rajah display this rook
captures Knight captures and now speeder
is up a whole piece but maybe maybe a
job of can do something with this passed
pawn he did try we got H for our rook to
h7 of course you have to put a rock
behind the passed pawn
either it doesn't matter if you're the
one promoting it your or your trying to
stop your opponent's pawn from being
promoted rooks belong behind passed
pawns that's the rule
rook to h2 and now King to be 4 and we
have h3 King to a5 and it was in this
position that he murdered a job of
resigned the game there's no way for
black to do anything with his passport
you could for example go route to D to
attack the night but after 94 you attack
the rook rook moves and after a 4
there's a really no way to do anything
here would like if you put upon then
white will gobble it up if you move the
rope
white will again gobble up the pond so
nothing really to do here or you can
even try something like for example
after King a five Ruby two can even go
Knight B 5 after black place for example
h2 now the ponies defended King b6 and
now you will either checkmate your
opponent or or if black stops this then
it will grab the h1 so very very simple
or instead of grabbing gauge 1 you can
even check make your opponent so it's a
nice position if you want if you want to
try out your puzzle or your tactics feel
free to pause and try to find a
checkmate in three for white there are
actually two checkmate to checkmate in
three so whichever you find it's
excellent and it's even better if you
find both so I will get a couple of
seconds if you want to decide for those
of you who found it congratulations you
are an excellent technician and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show one idea is Knight to c7 so after
Knight to c7 and this comes with check
our King has to move we have King to b8
now comes Knight to a6 check King again
has to move it doesn't matter if you go
to see it or you go to a eight whatever
you played and it's rock to c7 check or
if you move for example here then you
have rook here and this will also be
checkmate another idea is after black
stops this instead of going with this
variation Knight to c7 you can also go
rook to a7 immediately with check so
rook to a7 check our King moves now rook
the b7 check King moves doesn't matter
where the King moves if the King moves
here then it's night to a7 check if the
King moves here then it's Knight to c7
check so yeah after King a 5 or a job or
resign the game and a very nice win for
Peter Svidler so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it this is the last
game will be covering from round 3 and
from the next video we are going
straight into round 4 so as you've seen
Levon Aronian is firmly in the lead
after after three three rounds but we
already said that in our previous video
there will be a link to the article
about each round after after every video
so be sure to check it out as there is
a lot more to read about every round in
there in there and also some nice photos
will be in there as well so yeah I would
like to thank Adriano's Clayton Guild
Gabriel Jackson Tristan coeur-de-lion a
feeling and sorry dial Ayane fibbing and
zero design Corporation for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot I
really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
I would a nice video from round four of
the 2013 candidates tournament see you
soon